bonjour je m'appelle Guillaume cané je
vais réagir à des archives de
Lina bonjour Guillaume cané bonjour
alors vous avez été cavalier dans une
autre vie jeune premier réalisateur
couronné puis acteur confirmé alors on a
décidé de commencer l'entretien avec un
réalisateur qui comme vous savez très
bien s'entourer al quand on me dit vous
tournez souvent avec des vodettes là je
crois qu'il a vous parce qu'on veut
parler de mes petits potes en
l'occurrence parce que il y a longtemps
que je les connais moi tous ces gars-là
tu as pas l'air content tu es pas
c'estàd que moi je t'avais bien dit de
me faire un rôle tendre gentil qui
ressemblerait à mes à mes chansons tu
veux jouer tu veux pas jouer le docteur
chois il y a un truc qui ne me plaît pas
du tout on me tape dessus dans ce film
là pourquoi on me tape dessus moi j'aime
pas mais j'aime pas qu'on me tape dessus
alors qui plus on me tape sur ma tête
non c'est pas à snavour si c'était
Charles encore il est mignon il a un
format lui au moins acceptable mais
c'est l'autre grande brut là le
Venturin vas-y dislui ce que tu penses
il y a une révolte ou quoi ça non
pourquoi mais il Râ tous l'autre voulait
jouer un curé Piro se plain que tu lui
tape sur la tête je vois pas de quoi il
se plain c'est les deux autres qui
devrai se plaindre puisque tu les butes
dans le
truc alors toi tu as pas à te plaindre
une petite chose quand même j'e pas
beaucoup la scène TR de brut quoi c'est
[Rires]
ça c'est extraordinaires ces images
j'aurais tellement aimé être avec eux là
c'est c'est c'est tout ce que j'aime
j'adore comme il parle j'adore les
dialogues sont sont là déjà et vous
aussi vous aimez bien vous entourer de
vos petit potes comme dit odiar pour
tourner euh c'est toujours plus sympa de
travailler avec des gens qu'on aime
qu'avec des consin ça c'est sûr je pense
qu'on a quand même moins de difficultés
avec des gens qui vous respectent qui
vous qui vous font confiance et avec des
gens que que nous on on apprécie aussi
c'est toujours plus simple et une scène
comme ça ça vous est déjà arrivé vos
potes qui viennent et qui qui sont pas
contents des rôles que vous leur donnez
ou euh pas sur le plateau mais c'est
arrivit à la lecture du du scénario
quand on se fait une lecture tous
ensemble on a l'impression d'être mal
servi oui ça ça m'est ça m'est déjà
arrivé là on voit bien quand même que
c'est un peu mis en scène he enfin les
les acteurs qui viennent parler ne
parlent pas comme ils parlent même même
Aznavour parle comme odiar on l'a vu
avec Astérix dernièrement vous vous
réalisez souvent des films avec des
castings prestigieux euh écoutez ce
qu'en pense agès Varda
écoutez même si les vettes sont des très
bons comédiens la plupart du temps et
c'est vrai je n'aime pas ce qu'il
représente je n'aime pas le star système
qui fait que les films se montrent comme
des affaires avec un bon roman des
comédiens fameux et ça s'est valu
uniquement en argent je n'aime pas
l'idée de participer à cette économie là
c'est pour ça je pense qu'il est plus
intéressant de faire un cinéma avec des
gens peu connus comédien cependant parce
que je pense que le travail correspond
mieux à une expression de cinéma un peu
fraîche un peu neuve un peu libre un peu
drôle tout ce qu'on veut même si
effectivement les stars sont des bons
comédiens personnellement je j'ai jamais
envie d'écrire ou de travailler avec des
stars j'aime beaucoup agès Varda B ce
qu'elle raconte oui effectivement est
fidèle à à son cinéma et à ce qu'elle
aime dans le cinéma maintenant moi je
trouve que le le le cinéma ça de
formidable c'est qu'il est il peut être
totalement différent il peut y avoir des
films avec des gens pas connus et moi
j'aime beaucoup aussi ce cinéma là et
puis il y a aussi il peut y avoir un
cinéma où on a plaisir à aller voir un
acteur que l'on aime et on a envie
d'aller le voir dans dans ce film c'est
un point de vue que je je je respecte ça
dépend des films que l'on a envie de
faire comme on a envie de les faire moi
je sais par exemple en tant que que
réalisateur qu'il y a des films où euh
je suis content de ne pas forcément pour
certains rôles employer des gens connus
parce que j'estime que c'est des
personnages qui ont besoin de ne pas
être
emprint de de trop de de trop de
notoriété et que on puisse découvrir des
rôles des personnages alors on part
maintenant à la rencontre d'un
réalisateur qui vous a beaucoup
influencé vous l'avez même rendu hommage
avec un film au début quand j'ai
commencé à faire des films enfin au
moment des valceuses les gens qui me
découvrai physiquement après qui venait
m'interviewer par exemple était tout à
fait stupéfait disait c'est pas vous qui
avez fait ça c'est pas possible mais
maintenant les gens se sentent habitués
c'est vrai que je ne ressemble pas à mes
filmes enfin en tout cas l'apparence
extérieure ne colle pas quoi dans la
tête c'est une autre affaire vous avez
une explication à cette à ce décalage
oui il est probable que il y a une
ambigué en moi fondamentale c'est-à-dire
que j'ai j'ai une apparence disons euh
plutôt bourgeoise alors qu'en fait
quelque part je dois être un voyou
est-ce que vous ressemblez à vos films
bah je pense qu'il y a déjà beaucoup de
mois dans mes films forcément puisque je
je les écris et que je me je me sers de
de de mon ressenti de de de ma manière
d'analyser certaines situations de mon
côté justement un petit peu décalé
parfois de mon cynisme et ça je pense
que oui je pense que certains certains
de mes films euh me ressemble pas mal il
y a des choses très très personnelles
que je raconte dans lui sur ce ce
personnage ce double qui longtemps m'a
m'a tiré vers le bas m'a empêché d'avoir
une certaine confiance en moi et et ça
effectivement le film me ressemble
beaucoup par rapport à ça aujourd'hui
vous êtes à la fiche d'acide une fiction
haltante sur fond de catastrophe
écologique en regardant acide on a
essayé de trouver des traces dans les
archives du phénomène des plus acide
regardez ce qu'on a trouvé cause
principale de l'acidité atmosphérique
les transports à eux seuls les gaz
d'échappement routier fournissent 35 %
des émalations toxiques 30 autres%
résultent des carburants brûlés par
l'ind ind et le chauffage domestique des
particules émises par les pots
d'échappement où les cheminées d'usine
se mêent au nuage les chargeants de
vapeur d'acide nitrique ou sulfurique
bien entendu la pluie contaminée tombe
souvent très loin ainsi on a constaté
que des fumées émises à Londre pouvaient
empoisonner de jours plus tard des lacs
suédois est-ce que vous vous êtes écho
anxieux c'est pas d'être échoanxieux on
devrait tous l'être en fait c'est plutôt
est-ce que vous êtes anxieux
euh oui je suis anxieux de donner une
appellation comme ça à certaines
personnes c'est-à-dire que on catalogue
certaines personnes en fait on met
certaines personnes dans un coin en se
disant voilà bah lui il fait partie des
échos anxieux ça voudrait dire que tout
le monde n'a pas forcément à être
anxieux on est au courant si on se
renseigne un tout petit peu et qu'on
écoute les scientifiques qui vous
explique de manière extrêmement claire
que dans 25 30 ans ça va être très très
compliqué et que la là il est déjà
presque trop tard pour faire demi-tour
moi je je suis père de famille dans 25
30 ans si je ne l'étais pas bon je me
dirais c'est pas grave j'ai une belle
vie mais mes enfants dans 25 30 ans j'ai
pas envie que que ça que que ça s'arrête
là pour eux en fait mais déjà le fait
même de donner une appellation et de
dire est-ce que vous vous êtes écho
anxieux ça prouve que déjà on n pas
ensemble et c'est ça qui m'inquiète en
fait on va écouter un acteur désormais à
qui vous vouliez ressembler quand vous
étiez enfants vous pratiquez aussi le
même sport que lui et Jean-Paul que
croyez-vous qu'il devienne quand il
cesse d'être pour vous Jean-Paul
Belmondo chaque fois qu'il le peut en
sortant du studio il redevient l'un de
ses boxeurs têtus qui viennent
s'entraîner chaque soir après leur
travail à l'Avia club chez Dupin
Derrière la Porte Saint-Martin peut-être
se dit-il comme vous que s'il n'avait
pas passé laatt d'après-midi dans son
adolescence à l'époque où il séchait les
cours du conservatoire il n'aurait pas
aujourd'hui ce profil tendre sauvage et
appar Méch de jeunes premier blouson
noir il y a un rapport vous croyez entre
le fait que vous soyez aussi passionné
de boxe et les rôles que vous jouer
oui certainement parce que ça m'a
apporté enfin cet emploi au cinéma
c'estd un emploi un peu dur oui et la
boxe m'avait donné justement ce ce côté
enfin harneux dans la vie c'est ne pas
se laisser démonter quand ça va malce
que c'est
Lane c'est c'est pour moi enfin c'est le
du moins dans un ring c'est la volonté
de gagner qui vous donne cette sorte de
Harne et hors du ring et ben dans la vie
aussi c'est de s'accrocher quand ça va
mal et puis quand on est un peu
désespéré de pas s'écouter de continuer
à lutter et je crois que j'ai appris ça
avec la boxe
ou c'est c'est c'est marrant de voir ces
images là à cet âge-là qui traduisent si
bien l'homme qu'il a toujours été même
après dans la difficulté avec tout ce
qu'il a vécu vers la fin de sa vie
Jean-Paul reste pour nous un modèle
incroyable de
tenénacité de joie euh tout le temps
tout le temps heureux tout le temps de
bonne humeur tout le temps malgré toutes
les choses qu'il a pu rencontrer dans sa
vie et avec un avec un talent fou déjà
parce que c'est pas que les cascades
c'est aussi la l'acteur est ce qu'il a
réussi à imposer dans sa dans dans dans
son jeu qui est quand même des fois
extrêmement large et qui pourrait sonner
faux mais il a imposé et il a créé ce
personnage génial et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que vous aimez bien
les sport extrême en général et quand
vous travaillez quand vous filmez on dit
beaucoup que vous travaillez jusqu'à
épuisement parfois même au détriment de
votre santé est-ce que vous assumez un
côté extrême je pense que j'ai besoin de
l'adrénaline c'est ce qui me motive
c'est ce qui me fait avancer j'ai
toujours eu ça et je pense que quand
j'en ai plus ça me manque une volonté de
de faire un maximum de choses et de
profiter de la vie un maximum tant
pendant qu'il en a encore temps avec
cette angoisse justement que le temps se
réduise ou que on puisse demain ne plus
être là vous avez aussi déploré que à la
fin de sa vie enfin qu'il avait passé
les dernières années de sa vie tout seul
oui est-ce que ça vous fait peur ça oui
oui oui bien
sûr c'est un métier très très dur pour
ça en fait c'est dire que les gens ont
tendance souvent à oublier et à voir
leur leur leur nombril et c'est vrai que
Jean-Paul je trouve que les dernières
années de sa vie
euh j'ai pas eu j'ai pas vraiment eu
l'impression qu'on on on l' accompagné
comme il le méritait en fait c'est mon
opinion est-ce que le cinéma doit
refléter la société française ou reflète
la société française on écoute Yve
Boissé répondre à cette question en
1974 moi j'ai l'impression que la
misogynie du cinéma en général et du du
cinéma en particulier du cinéma français
en particulier qui est réel c'est vrai
c'est pas une légende elle ressort d'un
problème beaucoup plus grave qui est le
le fait que le cinéma français ne donne
en aucune manière un reflet exact de la
société française à l'heure actuelle et
des préoccupation de notre temps et
c'està-dire que si par exemple on
imagine que dans deux ou trois siècles
des archéologues se pencha sur la
société française en 1975 uniquement
avec comme seule base de document des
films français il seraient absolument
étonné parce qu'ils auraient
l'impression que la France était en 1975
un pays peuplé exclusivement de flic de
bandit de mannequins de coverg en ce qui
concerne les femmes de prostituées de
quelques journalistes et pour le reste
éventuellement de milliardaires ou de
rigolo qui passent leur temps à
s'envoyer des tartes à la crème moi je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec ce qu'il
dit je trouve que même par rapport à à
son époque quand on voit les films film
de sauter quand on voit les films de
truffo quand on voit je trouve que ça
reflète plutôt bien la société de
l'époque en fait quand on voit les films
de Blier quand on voit les valceuses je
trouve que ça réflète très très bien la
société de l'époque quand on voit tenue
de soirée je trouve que ça réflète très
très bien la société de l'époque et
aujourd'hui les films d'aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il reflètent la société de
l'époque oui oui j'ai j'ai enfin oui
j'ai l'impression ENF peut-être que je
me peut-être je me trompe mais j'ai
l'impression que il y a quand même une
réflexion sur la société actuelle sur
euh sur la sexualité sur la politique
sur l'environnement sur sur
ouais enfin je je je suis pas je suis
pas vraiment d'accord avec ce que dis VO
c'est alors on a parler de l'entourage
mais l'entourage c'est aussi la vie hors
caméra on va écouter une immense légende
du cinéma qui parle non pas de son
travail mais de sa vie personnelle pour
moi la chose la plus difficile de de
vraiment de réussir en plus de gens
jeunes comme nous deux de faire une vie
ensemble une vie une vraie vie à côté de
ce métier c'est plus important que le
métier oui pour moi oui et c'était pas
avant j'étais bien prêt prête à me
livrer corps et âme comme on dit chez
nous à ce métiers mais ça ça ça m'a fait
bien peur un moment parce que si c'est
bien un moment où ça peut s'arrêter
surtout pour pour une femme un jour on
est plus jeune on est plus
jolie et puis si ça s'arrête on a plus
rien si on a pas quelqu'un ou une vie ou
un coin où on peut aller ou un enfant
non gen non pour moi c'est j'ai quelque
chose au-dessus de ce métiers je
m'accroche bien et ça je vais me
garder chement d'accord avec ce qu'elle
dit avec
l'importance effectivement d'avoir
quelque chose dans sa vie qui nous
nourrisse et qui nous permett de nous
réparer des films aussi que l'on
fait de nous réparer aussi des
des coups que l'on prend dans ce métier
et je pense que c'est une une partie de
sa vie qu'il faut extrêmement protéger
et et et préserver parce que c'est ce
qui nous permet de pas devenir sec en
fait entre les
films il faut justement vivre il faut
justement aimer il
faut pleurer se réparer se se se
renourrir de beaucoup de choses pour ne
pas enchaîner film après film coup après
coup et à un moment être épuisé ne plus
avoir rien à dire parce que en fait
c'est ça aussi c'est qu'un acteur ce qui
est très important c'est que entre
chaque film il puisse pouvoir dire des
choses différentes qu'il a vécu dans
entre ses films et que du coup il va
peut-être avoir une approche un peu
différente sur le rôle qu'il va jouer et
ce vécu là il est essentiel donc cette
partie- làà pour moi est essentielle
c'està-dire que cette partie entre les
films dans la vie privée est essentielle
les gens savent à quel c'est quelque
chose qui pour moi une ch
gardée écoutez ce que Jerry Lewis disait
au sujet des acteurs qui
réalise
moi c'est pour ça que aime beaucoup
aussi travailler avec des des
réalisateurs qui sont acteurs parce
qu'ils comprennent ça en fait ils
comprennent le le mécanisme ils
comprennent la manière dont un acteur
travaille et et créer un un personnage
et c'est vrai que dans les deux sens
d'ailleurs c'estàd que même moi en tant
qu'acteur me retrouver sur un plateau
avec un metteur en scène et de voir qu'à
un moment il traverse un moment
compliqué avec l'équipe parce que il y a
un problème à régler que de ça je sais
que c'est pas le bon moment pour aller
le voir et lui demander un peu
d'attention et comme expliqué tout à
l'heure que les acteurs des fois on
besoin d'avoir un papa et une maman et
et d'avoir des petits câlins quoi donc
ça ça m'aide aussi en tant qu'acteur
enfin en tant que réalisateur quand je
me retrouve sur un plateau en tant
qu'acteur de voir que il y a un certain
respect à avoir pour le mteur en scène
et une confiance surtout et de se dire
que s'il m'a demandé ça c'est qu'il sait
ce qu'il fait et pourquoi il le fait en
fait donc moi ça m'aide beaucoup dans
les deux cas en tout cas dans votre vie
il y a eu des hauts des bas des
rebondissements mais aussi des chutes et
là on va regarder la chute la plus
célèbre de l'histoire épique ce cheval
tout seul c'est japllou l'animal qui
aurait dû permettre à l'équipe de France
d'équitation de remporter une médaille
dans le concours par équipe l'échéance
était simple pour Pierre Duran le
cavalier français Sam monure effectuer
un parcours sans faute s'il voulait
obtenir une médaille de bronze pour leur
équipe malheureusement sur un obstacle
simple tout sécroulé pour les
Français refus du cheval et du cavalier
au ralenti l'homme a bien franchi
l'obstacle mais pas la monture c'est
interdit la France n'a donc pas sa
médaille par équipe l'aura-t-elle en
individuel la foulée était pas bonne
c'est terrible parce que c'est le
meilleur cheval au monde et c'est vrai
que c'est c'est une scène c'est un
moment terrible pour le pour le cavalier
pour le cheval
euh voilà cette incompréhension sur ce
départ sur cette foulée qui est qui est
qui est trop longue et le cheval ne part
pas bon bon il a prouvé derrière que se
remettre en selle et travailler et et
puis persévérer lui a permis de devenir
champion olympique à c'estou après donc
ça fait partie de la vie c'est les
chutes effectivement il faut savoir se
relever c'est le bon exemple de savoir
que il faut se relever voilà ah ben vous
avez ces images là c'est dingue
voilà là j'ai pris des trous de crampon
sur la main dans le dos je me suis pété
tout le côté droit là en fait parce que
je me prends le cheval me marche dessus
après vous allez voir là je passe en
dessous c'est terrifiant voilà et là il
me
pétine voilà tac là il me piétine mais
là c'est la même chose hein la foulée
est trop longue vous pouvez nous
raconter un peu cette chute justement
bah c'est à mesqu à côté pas loin de la
Baule où le weekend d'avant je fais 2è
d'une épreuve nocturne à La Baule sur le
grand terrain stade François André où
j'étais très très fier parce que c'était
une grosse épreuve je demande une foulée
improbable au cheval qui qui qui part
une sous une foulée avant et et bah qui
a pas le la possibilité de passer
l'obstacle et qui qui dedans et
je tombe et il il me il me marche dessus
et je me pète le poignet luxation de
l'épaule le des trous dans le dos avec
les crampons je pète des côtes je me
pète le pied enfin voilà une grosse
partie du du côté droit et le poignet un
peu en 1 morceaux C ouais c'était une
une chute assez assez violente et après
j'ai commencé à monter pendant pendant
quelques temps pendant un an avec avec
un plâtre euh et puis après j'ai arrêté
j'ai décidé d'arrêter parce que parce
que j'avais 17 18 ans et que je
montais tout le temps tous les weekends
je faisais 400 bornes pour aller faire
tomber une barre des fois et que c'était
voilà c'était un moment de ma vie où
j'avais envie de de de faire du cinéma
j'avais envie d'aller à Paris j'avais
envie de de connaître une autre vie que
ça en fait on va vous montrer une image
exceptionnelle de l'acteur qui vous a
mis le pied à l'étrier dans le cinéma un
chapanzé derrière une grille dans un
zoau si on a le temps et plein de
d'enseignement pour après imiter
retrouver des
hommes j'essaie de le faire triste là
regarder
il a de sa colère
aussi il a de beaux
gestes
avz jamais vu des images de lui aussi
jeune en train de le faire je savais pas
qu'il imitait déjà le champoné à C âge
là mais oui j'ai une inection très très
particulière P Jean c'était vraiment mon
mon père spirituel je je l'ai connu
justement à ce moment-là après la chute
enfin je l'ai connu avant moi je le
voyais avant en concours tout le temps
il était là parce que c'était la figure
du cinéma qui venait au concours parce
qu'il était passionné de chevaux et la
personne chez qui je m'entraînais euh et
qui montait d'ailleurs nacheville le
cavalier qui s'appelle jean-maaurice
bonau et qui montait son son son cheval
m'entraîner avec Marina Hans d'ailleurs
on était tous les deux on s'entraînait
dans ses écuries mais lui m'a jamais
vraiment connu et c'est des années plus
tard que que quand j'ai commencé à faire
du théâtre et du et de et des téléfilms
que on s'est on a pu se parler et que et
que là il m'a il m'a permis de faire ce
film qui s'appelait Barracuda qui était
mon premier film au cinéma et de là on a
eu une complicité énorme où il a
toujours été
extrêmement affectueux généreux curieux
de tout ce que je faisais et et j'ai le
souvenir de souvent le dimanche soir
souvent il m'appelait pour me me faire
le bilan des quand j'avais un film qui
sortait en général et le il le voyait il
me faisait le
bilan de de ce qu'il avait vu et de ce
qu'il pensait de mon travail et c'était
des moments à chaque fois vraiment
extraordinaires alors c'est le moment
pour moi d'arrêter de vous poser des
questions et c'est le moment pour vous
de choisir qui va vous poser la
prochaine entre Philippe Bouvard Henry
Chapier Denise Glazer et Christine
Bravo j'ai pas un grand souvenir de
Denise Glazer donc je vais choisir
Denise Glazer pour la curiosité n'
jamais eu peur de de grandchose dans
votre vie si si j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai
surtout j'ai surtout eu peur de moi en
fait merci beaucoup Guillaume Canet
merci à
[Musique]
vous